Hey everyone, my name is Crawley and welcome to module one.
Let's be entirely honest. When most people hear the word insurance, their brains immediately picture dense stacks of dry legal paperwork. But insurance isn't just modern red tape. It is an epic centuries old story of human community survival.
In this session, we are turning back the clock to explore the history of insurance, uncover core definitions, map out the characteristics of insurable risks, look at contract structures, and break down the six general principles that keep the modern financial world spinning.
Let's jump into the time machine. Our first destination is ancient Babylon around 1700 BC under the rule of King Hammurabi.
Inside the famous Code of Hammurabi, we find the earliest documented roots of a collective community safety net. The laws dictated that if a robber was not caught, the local community held a structural obligation to step in and fully compensate the victim for whatever had been lost.
Furthermore, if a citizen was kidnapped, the community was legally bound to pay exactly one min of silver to their family as ransom.
Centuries later, the structural forerunners of modern commercial insurance shifted to Italy. Maritime merchants needed a smart way to protect dangerous sea voyages, leading to early financial instruments like bottomry bonds and respondentia.
While Europe was developing commercial bonds, systems of mutual protection were evolving in the Philippines. These included paluwagan as a local pooling system, bayanihan as community cooperation, and abuloy as collective financial support during hardship.
In 1689 London, Edward Lloyd’s coffee house became a meeting point for merchants and shipowners negotiating maritime insurance agreements. This later evolved into Lloyd’s of London, which is not a single insurance company but a marketplace of underwriters.
The insurance industry in the Philippines formally expanded through colonial trade links and institutions, beginning in the 19th century with early foreign agencies and later local companies such as non-life and life insurers established in the early 1900s.
Today, insurance is supported by organizations like professional associations and actuarial societies, which help stabilize the industry and support risk pooling, credit systems, and national economic resilience.